[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP j'ai le
grand plaisir d'être en présence de
Frédéric Tellier que je salue Frédéric
Tellier bonjour et ben bonjour bonjour à
tous merci d'être avec rrou on se voit
régulièrement voilà on s'était vu ah oui
c'est gentil on s'était vu en 2018 vous
êtes versaillet vous êtes réalisateur et
vous aviez participé à une association
qui s'appelle un artiste à l'école et on
était au collège pour carré où vous avez
usé vos fond de culotte comme on dit
couramment voilà depuis bah le temps a
passé aujourd'hui c'est une
avant-première l'avant-première d'un
biopic qui vient de qui sort le 8
novembre qui s'appelle la BA pierre une
vie de combat ouais voilà et on on est
là pour ça on va en parler merci merci
merci à vous ben écoutez c'est un grand
plaisir alors en fait vous êtes le
réalisateur de l'affaire esc1 le
réalisateur de sauver au périr le
réalisateur de Goliath et là aujourd'hui
sort donc laabé pierre une vie de combat
est-ce que une sorte de logique avec ce
ce dernier film par rapport à à à
l'humanité à comment dire vous dévoilez
un humain un destin hors norme une vie
de combat un homme de combat est-ce
est-ce qu'il y a une logique ou ou bien
sûr pour moi il y a une il y a une
logique j'espère qu'elle n'est pas une
obsession mais qu'elle est plutôt une
logique c'est vrai que ce cette étude du
du de la confrontation du mal du bien me
m'interpelle beaucoup dans mes dans mes
film c'est pas rationnel hein c'est
c'est c'est comme ça mais c'est ce que
j'aime explorer et là évidemment c'était
un en revanche j'aime changer de de
vraiment d'outils à chaque fois c'est
vraiment autre choseuniv je d'univers
complet de de moyens pour y arriver mais
pour moi ça reste ce ce ce sillon que
j'essaie de de de creuser de avec pour
le coup là un combattant un combattant
du mal au nom du Bien euh voilà donc oui
on est dans ma tête on est dans des
mêmes logiques oui on est d'accord et
alors là vous nous montrez euh donc ce
cet abbé Pierre qui finalement est un
homme de combat mais qui qui à la base
n'est pas tellement fait pour ça vous
vous nous le montrez aussi agile enfin
comment vous avez eu cette idée
d'ailleurs de de d'aborder ce sujet en
fait l'idée elle était dangereuse parce
que l'idée de faire un récit
cinématographique biographique sur
l'abbé était hyper séduisante mais après
il faut se mettre au travail c'estàd
qu'est-ce qu'on raconte et moi
j'espérais trouver derrière une vie
intéressante c'était l'étude du
personnage qui me qui me plaisait le le
personnage au milieu
C éé qui a été sa vie sur un
siècle le film raconte de ses 20 ans à
sa disparition 94 ans 75 ans de notre
histoire 2007 2007 ouais en janvier 2007
donc le le Paris c'était ça alors bah
donc comme j'aime bien faire à chaque
fois j'ai j'ai gratté comme on dit che
chez vous chez les journalistes j'ai
enquêté je suis allé et là je suis tombé
sur une vie
absolument sidérante parce qu'en fait je
vous coupe la parole on connait il y a
eu le film l'appel de l'Oliver 54 qui
qui est un moment très ponctuel vous au
contraire vous couvrez donc presque un
siècle de à travers ça l'histoire de de
la France et et donc vous avez dû vous
documenter énormémentormément ou et vous
aviez déjà l'idée que ça soit que il
avait eu les chifonier d'maus aussi
avant 56 qui était aussi sur la période
de la la mise la mise en place de du
mouvement Maus il y a eu appel 54 et moi
c'est vraiment comme je vous disais en
en grattant sur le sujet où je me suis
dit en fait c'est sa vie qui m'a j'avais
envie de trouver l'homme derrière
qu'est-ce qu'il fait pourquoi on devient
l'abbé comment on tient aussi longtemps
comment on devient ce paradoxe c'est
tout ça est est très est très intrigant
à explorer en fait quoi oui c'est très
intéressant parce qu'il est il est
finalement porté galvanisé par par ses
combats en fait ça lui donne une force
énorme et et et puis c'était un phénix
et puis il s'effondrait il disparaissait
il tombait malade il renaissait de ses
cendbres et hop te au combat sur un
combat unique quoi le combat pour la
générosité la bonté ouais contre
l'injustice ouais et et et alors du coup
quand vous avez cherché enfin quand vous
êtes documenté quand vous avez gratté
comme vous dites est-ce que parfois vous
parce que c'est quand même une très
longue période est-ce que vous êtes
tombé sur des informations
contradictoires parce que c'était quand
même quelqu'un qui laissait pas
indifférent moi j'ai fait ça sur tous
mes films que vous avez gentiment citer
mes films de cinéma mais j'avais fait ça
aussi en télé avant je je n'ai traité
que des histoir hisire vraie c'est aussi
autre chose qui m'intéresse donc c'est
devenu un petit exercice j'ai pas de
formation journalistique je suis très
totalement autodidacte avec tout le
mauvais côté de ça mais j'ai quand même
appris au fil du temps à recouper des
pistes et à commencer à m'intéresser au
moment où j'ai des croisements j'ai trop
d'avis contradictoires je sais qu'il y a
un truc qui qui cloche quoi il peut y
avoir des avis divergents mais à un
moment il faut que je les recoupe mes
pistes pour être sûr du fait que donc là
bien sûr j'ai des des contradictions des
des avis des sentiments cont victoire
mais factuellement ce que j'ai mis dans
le film c'est ce que j'ai vérifié et qui
ça s'est passé comme ça bon et alors
Benjamin la Verne donc de la Comédie
Française qui qui est incroyable dans le
rôle il est il est vraiment puis c'est
lui tout le temps enfin il a un travail
de maquillage énorme j'imagine parce que
il y a pas d'image d'archive c'est lui
tout le temps tout le temps même si
effectivement il y a des moments on me
dit mais là c'est une image d'archive on
perd totalement
l'acteur Benjamin j'avais tourné avec
lui dans l'affire S il avait un petit
rôle
euh voilà il était resté dans ma dans ma
zone d'observation disons de manière
très modeste et on en a beaucoup parlé
avec Wasim Beji le le producteur on
avait très envie de lui parce qu'il
remplissait toutes les toutes les cases
en fait c'estàd grande technicité grande
solidité le rôle allait être compliqué
il allait être exigeant compliqué
physiquement psychologiquement
émotionnellement donc on voulait un
acteur très très auut point très solide
é à
euh moi en connaissant Benjamin j'aimais
aussi ces paradoxes c'est un homme de
Paradox j'aimais son sa capacité à
s'émouvoir et sa capacité à mettre de la
distance sur des situations je trouvais
que ça pouvait être un vrai atout pour
pour faire le le rôle et puis ensuite
pour me convaincre et le convaincre j'ai
aussi fait des séances d'essaiis très
classique parce que j'avais envie de
voir s'il en avait envie du du rôle pas
que prendre la proposition parce qu'elle
est unique mais aussi s'il avait envie
du travail de du mimétisme je voulais
qu'il soit très proche qu' se fonde dans
dans la baie que ce soit pas une une
interprétation que ce soit vraiment une
une composition autour du personnage de
l'AB baie donc voilà c'est un peu tout
ça qui qui a
abouti à ce que à ce que ce soit lui et
à ce travail
épousouflant où il devient l'abbé quoi
vraiment ouis complètement et alors je
me demandais c'était quoi enfin on le
voit dans le film bien sûr mais la
relation avit entre lu C qui est joué
par Emmanuel Berco et le laabé pierre
c'est c'est une des grandes révélations
du du film que j'ai découverte moi je
connaissais pas cette histoire ou si peu
je pensais que c'était sa secrétaire et
puis voilà et en fait ça a été sa sa
compagne de route sa compagne de vie
parce qu'ils ont vécu 40 ans ensemble le
film révèle principalement ça et
beaucoup d'autres choses sur sa vie mais
principalement qu'ils ont vécu dans des
petits appartements tous les deux des
petites maisons ça a été une un grand
amour
pas vraiment platonique c'est autre
chose spirituelle d'une autre dimension
ça a été des compagnons de route
vraiment des compagnon de vie quoi elle
a fait partie des piliers qui l'ont qui
l'ont soutenu bien sûr est cofondatrice
du mouvement Emaus dans dans les dans la
légalité avec lui dans les statuts
légaux donc c'est une femme qui était
très discrète qui est resté dans l'ombre
c'était une très grande résistante ils
se sont connus pendant la résistance
enfin le film va faire découvrir tout ça
mais ouais c'est c'est une c'est
bouleversant parce que elle était plus
âgée que lui elle est partie avant lui
s'en est jamais
remis c'était son âme sœur vraiment
l'âme sœur quoi ça a été son son âme
sœur et effectivement on ne connaît pas
cette histoire ben voilà on la découvre
elle est belle et et du coup vous
pensiez que ça serait alors le film faut
le dire il dure 2h20 ouais on les voit
pas passer ouais on est pris on est
Ballé on est emporté donc c'est c'est un
spectacle ce film c'est une épopée c'est
vraiment un film de cinéma quoi parce
que ça a vraiment été un travail qu'on a
fait avec le producteur dès le début on
s'est dit on veut on veut rêver du film
comme un comme un grand film de cinéma
enfin pas au sens prétentieux mais au
sens de la
proposition une épopée un benur français
de des des grands bon l'histoire s'y
prêtait mais on voulait vraiment donner
du rythme en fait là vous parlez du
rythme pas que de la dimension
émotionnelle ou artistique mais le le
rythme du film Le être bringballé dans
les émotions être avec eux de d'être
très intime avec lui et Lucy et George
Legay le premier compagnon interprété
par par Michel villermos est avec les
compagnons dans la communauté et puis
vivent des grandes choses quand il se
bat pour la contre le froid contre donc
voilà c'est un mélange de tout ça qu'on
a voulu ramasser parce qu'on aurait pu
faire un film de de 3 He aussi moi je
voulais un film quand même tenu en 2h 2h
et qu oui vous saviez déjà que ça allait
être très long enfin très long oui mais
on aurait pu faire faire plus long moi
je voulais vraiment que les
grands-parents puissent venir avec les
enfants alors vous parlez des
grands-parents il est pour quel public
ce film moi je sais mais nous on l'a
rêvé pour tout public on l'a vraiment
rêvé tout public tout tout a été fait
pour que ce soit tout public non pas
comme un comme une une une une une
avidité une cupidité de choper tout le
monde mais on s'est dit le message est
tellement fort tellement universel
tellement beau qu'on a envie que ceux
qui l'ont connu les plus âgés viennent
on a rêvé de de qui viennent avec leurs
enfants de 40 50 ans qui tiennent par le
bras qui eux-mêmes reviennent avec leur
leurs enfants de 15 20 ans découvrir
cette grande figure de notre histoire
cette cette grande histoire romanesque
et et et historique de notre vécu pour
découvrir ce personnage donc il est il
est fait de manière assez large il est à
la fois très très émouvant à la fois
très épique comme on a dit c'est c'est
un grand spectacle en fait on grand et
alors il est d'autant plus d'actualité
que en ce moment ben les restos du cœur
manque de de bénévoles sont complètement
débordés et Maus n'a jamais vu autant de
de monde dans dans ses comment ça
s'appelle dans ses maisons enfin ses
communauté il y a même les gens viennent
de plus en plus se fournir chez US de
par la provuté et alors est-ce que vous
pensez que V votre film ça pourrait
réveiller réveiller quelqu'un un autre à
ba pied ou alors un autre réveiller nous
z-nous déjà oui je pense que forcément
oui d'autant que on se parle là j'ai
déjà fait plusieurs projections je je
vois bien l'impact que que ça le
j'espère qu'il sera durable
surtout maintenant révéler un autre Abé
pierre je je j'aimerais profondément on
en a besoin est-ce que ça pourrait
exister à notre époque la sociologie
serait intéressante à à réfléchir je je
je sais pas en tous les cas c'est
évident que la situation on a eu
beaucoup de de questions de
questionnement nous mais de questions
aussi extérieur sur le sujet est-ce que
la situation s'est dégradée oui elle
n'arrête pas de de se dégrader est-ce
que le le combat est perdu oui la nature
humaine s'autodétruit c'est c'est un des
points moi qui me fascine dans mon
travail d'étudier ça pourquoi la nature
humaine
s'autodétruit en revanche la nature
humaine est magnifique aussi c'està-dire
que si on ne menait pas ce combat il
serait totalement perdu d'avance il faut
le mener pour pas le perdre complètement
pour rester dans l'humanité rester dans
l'échange dans ne pas oublier qu'on a
plus de raisons de se détester que de
s'aimer mais que la grande beauté c'est
de s'aimer de s'apprécier de s'enrichir
je parle pas d'aimer moi je suis pas
religieux je parle pas de oui il y a des
connards qui nous énervent mais on peut
quand même avoir de la considération
même pour eux de l'empathie s'interroger
sur la complexité de la vie c'est c'est
tout ça que que que nous redit l'abbé de
manière simple et engagée en fait quoi
et puis c'est surtout ce qui dit c'est
que en ça capacité à s'indigner à se
révolter à pas faire il dit enfin dans
votre film j'aime accueillir les
événements c'est c'est faire aussi feu
de tout bois et puis ne pas faire comme
tout le monde parce que un moment les
les financiers lui lui conseillent de de
placer l'argent lui dit non on va tout
dépenser on va tout de suite construire
des cités d'urgence faut acheter des
terrains et cetera donc il en fait entre
guillemets qu' sa tête comme il peut et
et c'est ça aussi qui manque aujourd'hui
c'est les les gens qui qui ruent un peu
dans les brancards et qui bien sûr oui
oui et puis des gens qui sont restés
je j'ai souvent pensé aussi que ce film
étudié comme comme la plupart de mes
films d'ailleurs les les dérive
cognitive de notre société je j'ai
toujours pas trouvé la réponse mais et
qu'un personnage comme laabbé sont des
personnages qui m'intéressent parce que
ce sont des personnages de bon sens ils
ont un sens pratique assez simple pas de
champ des sirènes juste être simple être
heureux profiter de la
vie SR des jotion action aussi voilà
c'est ça mais mais jamais avec une
perspective l'abbé Pierre ce qui est
fascinant c'est qu'il est toujours resté
en bas de l'échelle hiérarchique
ecclésiastique il a jamais eu de de de
désir de de réussir de son
épanouissement il le voyait à travers la
paix pareil la la paix au sens simple
être en paix les uns avec les autres
puisquon est là ensemble autant être en
paix quoi plutôt que de détruire l'autre
pour prendre sa place donc c'est un
grand si ce n'est un message parce que
ce serait peut-être présomptueux mais
euh en tous les cas un petit petite une
petit refreshing pour nous de de de se
questionner un petit questionnement pour
nous quoi juste de voilà ça peut nous
faire réviser un peu notre notre propre
copie finalement HM bon bah écoutez un
grand penseur finalement c'était un
grand penseur hein l'abbé oui mais aussi
toujours dans l'actionoursac c'est ça
qui fait sa force quoi malgré sa sa
fragilité c'est ses défauts ENF oui
parce qu'il était très concret il savait
qu'il suffisait pas de parler il fallait
avoir des résultats concrets construire
des maisons il le dit dans le fil même
si es sont mal construites et au moins
on met des gens à l'abri quelques mois
quelques semaines donner des couvertures
même si elles vont pas être durables
mais donner des couverture nourrir des
gens vous nous donnez l'argent il doit
dépensé tout de suite c'était son truc
qui rendait dingue les les financiers
tout de suite dépenser rien garder pour
nous pas pas avoir l'ivresse de ça
dépenser pour ceux qu'on ont le plus
besoin et puis la grande pensée de
l'abbé servir avant soi qui est plus
malheureux que soi c'est c'est c'était
ça sa grande pensé il est même allé
jusqu'à faire la la Manche ouais la
Manche la greffe de la fin qu'on VO ai a
dans dans le film avec les 100 les les
100 papiers ouais ouais bon merci pour
ce magnifique film hein qui marque don
on se souvient qu'on se souviendra
longtemps donc ça sort le 8 novembre et
bah à très bientôt j'espère avec grand
plaisir PL merci à vous merci au revoir
au revoir à
tous